Hôm qua 1 bệnh tháng 5,5 năm 2018, trong khoa trình thực hiện nhiệm vụ sê dựng công sình
cuối phòng tại đã cuối bệnh lo ngủy, thêm phó hài phòng, hà sĩ cao tình Anh,
sinh 5,5 năm, quên sá vĩnh thịt thịt thêm phó hài phòng, trên sĩ Trung đội 2, đại đổi
công bình mề bệnh phòng tham yêu, bộ trình vui quyết sử thêm phó hài phòng, đã giống cảm
cử đồng đội khỏi khu vực viêng và hí sinh. Theo đó, khoảng 12,5 phút cùng ngày, tại
phút được thực hiện nhiệm vụ sê dà sật lời đã đã phát hiện bình yến bình yên,
trên sĩ cũng đơn vị đặc ở khu vực viêng, hà sĩ cao tình Anh đã nhìn trong lâu tới,
đề đồng xí với bình yên giá khỏi khu vực sật lời.
Này sau khi xú tực sê dà, đơn vị đã hình chương tổ chức ứng cứu, đưa 2 con nhân giá khỏi khu vực sật lời
và trên đến chương tâm y tế đã khu vật lòng vĩ cấp cứu, mặc dù được gắn bộ,
nhân viên tế thình chương cứu chữa, ra bị thương quá nặp, đến mỗi dởi nằm phút cùng ngày,
hà sĩ cao tình Anh đã không qua họ, mình yên yên yên yên yên bị chân thương, được cấp cứu kì thời,
hẹn tình táo và đáng tức tục đực thân sỏi, đưa sĩ tại trong tâm y tế đã khu vật lòng vĩ.
Này nhìn hình đồng giống cảm cứu đồng đội trong khi thực hiện nhiệm vụ,
bộ sì vế có sự thịt phó hệ phòng đã quy định sĩ thân quân hàng từ hà sĩ lên chương sĩ đối với đồng xí cao tình Anh.
Nhi nhìn hình đồng giống cảm của đồng xí, hôm nay, chủ tịch nước tối lâm đã trí tặng hân chương bảo vệ tục quốc hạm mà và chủ ương đần thân
cộ sản hủ chiming đã trí tặng mọi khai đời với chung sĩ cao tình Anh.
Hình đồng giống cảm, không quan hiểm quyết kiểu đồng đội trong thời khách miền của chung sĩ cao tình Anh thì giảm sâu sách tình đồng xí.
Đồng đội, tinh thân chức nhiệm và phần chức cao đẹp của người quân nhân các mạng,
có phần bà sáng hình Anh có đẹp bộ đội của hộ thời kiếm mới.